the argument being made is that the
Republicans are beginning to go soft on
Ukraine at the elite level and that if
Donald Trump gets elected there's a
really good chance that he'll pull the
plug on the ukrainians uh this is not
going to happen in my opinion the United
States is backing Ukraine to the hilt
and if the United States withdraws its
support for Ukraine its material support
Ukraine is going to collapse it can't
stand up to the Russians the Russians
would win a big victory it's hard for me
to imagine that any American leader
whether it's Donald Trump or Joe Biden
is going to allow that to happen it's
just not going to happen we are too
deeply committed to this war there's too
much
russophobia in the United States